[Music]
good evening
would you watch less America what
they've been good
fights it's a movie based on a book
no she likes that she didn't like it
watching all that she finally you said
[Music]
papa
it's Sunday night [__] time to
write down your goals and get the week
ready you got a full week this week
that's it [__] you're sitting
there taking Halloween it's gonna come
[__] quick your Samsung is gonna blow
up and your [__] pocket [__]
they'll be the man on fire Jew on fired
you on fire does it dumb [__] insane
Greeks like to welcome you to church
[Laughter]
never a dull moment and the Voodoo
Lounge I'm here with my good buddy
Lee sciatica watching bad movies with
his girlfriend it always happens this
poor kid this book he lives in hell
usually got a [__] you watch what you
want this guy gets a blow job Annie
he watches bad TV he taps out he sits
there for an alcohol was a [__]
[Laughter]
once they suck your dick I hold the
cable box I'm in control
once you suck my dick it's over that's
it it's that time you have to get
yourself a bong for the house Lee smoke
signals is [__] here we go it was like
[__] Travis Browne last night long
Travis was it politically said I wanna
know what you man I wanna know ready to
kill that soldier Lisa hold on hold on
me ladies please kill that soldier oh
this is a goin this is one of those
bottom of the big box living your
fingers blow out live oh it's over it's
over there you go
[Music]
oh that bottle just smoking will kill
that kill that [__] salia good down
that's the bar gonna [__] spiral
there are you kidding me or what bong
hits in training bong hits with uncle
Joey you understand it DVD coming out
for Thanksgiving
you're [__] eyelids are sweat vis the
critical mass [__] from
perennial keep king keep bullshitting
yourself with that [__] weed they're
giving it back get listen get that stick
with little bag and you [__] get on a
train was smoking this [__] that kill
[__] Nostradamus you understand me
and you wanna sit there
talk about your [__] problems what
[__]
[Music]
oh there's nothing like doing 22 bonnets
on the Lord's Day you understand me
anybody could do a bonnet on a Monday
let me see you do 22 on a [__] Sunday
then come check it with me [__]
tremendous show tonight Sabbath dab is
calming friend of mine from the [__]
old days what else is going on Lisa at
see uncle Joey's here want to get you
all fired up for a [__] Monday
morning 911 all that [__] coming at
you we're gonna clear your mind there's
no 911 the only 911 is in my [__]
dick jack that's what's blowing the
[__] up 911 is a day of sorrow my
heart goes out to the [__] Americans but
we're moving on now is [__] if not ice
gonna [__] catch us and stuff
speaking of captionist it's time for a
bucket I'm pulsating glass no bone move
ass
[Music]
are you doing buddy all right you ready
for another party you sit there go put a
what Joey what am i a [__] mutt you
don't give me no fun beeps nothing
please sit they're gone
[Music]
[__] it where the ashes land the ashes
land I'm saying little more critical
lastly what the [__] this is the [__]
[Music]
there's the good [__] - there's that
bottom dust I tell you [__]
about I get the we to ten out of the dry
for about seven that break it up nice in
the car it's like a dust I keep breaking
it up then the bottom the bottom the
bottom once it gets to the bottom it's
over look at least say I'm smoking the
bottom of this lizard right here
wizard meet lizard bongs everything no
feet what the [__] is going on with this
country no moral thing what's going on
elite you're sucking or let's go is a
clock this [__] you're sucking
at that there
[Music]
now it's ready for this is tip-top Magoo
understand me when it comes to bond
repair yong-chol Joey's here
there you go there you go
coming in November Joey a basic
step-by-step manual you to do the most
bonds at the party in 30 days guaranteed
combining doctor polices breathing
exercises and my 30 years of [__] to hit
these bombs like you say honey buns I
[__] broken I could add my own bond
company by now but I've been [__] up
Lee I've been [__] insane
very nice nice album circa 1980 Ozzy
broke away like him 78 from Sabbath to
the year off doing [__] everything
his wife found them put together a band
around and this was the final result a
lot of circles is a very historic
[__] out does it changed a lot of
[__] things and he kept dick him
[Music]
what's up Lee
that's right baby boy [__] up is the
word tonight you're not gonna see the
devil turn me off by the way if you
eighteen get off right now [__] I
can't have you on here learning [__]
then you go to high school and you tell
your little [__] [__] friends I got
your mom tweeted me Joey's my son
smoking in the [__] attic
[Music]
we're hearing somebody I'm only known
ology at all he was even he was min old
finished [__] he would have already done
10 years and Black Sabbath and then they
broke up and then he got this and he did
you know another whatever this is it
this is like [__] historic this is
the first album right
about people oh this is [__] crazy
how this went down here 69 to 70
maybe the beginning of 79a program then
there was a big sabbatical then there
was rumors and then these [__]
came on board and took what was coming
to them Rudy Sarzo the [__] drummer
and in the front ahead roads
Randy [__] the roads and Ozzy put this
together so one [__] Rudy comes in
here
it's [__] big he is later the wife
took his tractor off and [__] him over
when he wrote the book and stuff oh yeah
are you [__] those Osbourne's
it'll [__] around anyway
what are you Joey what is this a [__]
history lesson with what's with the
[__] bongs let's get this party
started right
[Music]
apparently not
that was Carly
whoever [__] who was in here after us
every time he said if he's all those
guys assist what in the world is going
on every time he steps his foot this
[__] there we go
[Music]
there we go here we go ah what dog yeah
well they launched here it [__] lease
[__] up to it this is good weed I got
you know we think some over your [__]
around with these people I never bring
[__] susquehanna I always show up
with if that's what they tell me
I [__] take it you understand again
it's the bottom of this [__] nut if
you're anywhere in the vicinity I don't
give a [__] if you're Las Vegas grab
that bicycle [__] critical mass this
[__] will [__] put you in a coma
[__]
[Music]
from perennial mentor and Koufax
tell him uncle Joey sent you what's up
dog
oh that's right this smoke is [__] on
fire tonight every once in a while I get
some good reefer but every once in a
while I get some reefer that'll knock it
to a different [__] hemisphere oh
this one's it you understand me
I got a second matter five minutes fire
oh [__] here we go here we go you don't
want we just thing ain't kickin either I
gotta get some [__] water right here
that's what I think a little low that's
when the [__] bong is on fire
[Music]
the [__] disappear I'll send you
motherhood I went to [__] refill it
and give leave this last bondage oh yeah
oh yeah we're taking you for the murky
water you been [__] around for three
days you're not training you wanna trip
he's only a little reefer music oh [__]
oh [__] I might be out of reach oh no no
I got rethread the house that's right I
got a [__] number foot up for the
morning [__] that time is right love
will flow like wine tonight yeah
[Music]
to a paradise that's true and three yeah
let's do this
looking at then smoother than [__]
smooth
[Music]
you can
telling you guys get the bicycle get on
grandma's [__] Cordoba whatever the
[__] you got get in it does this weed
ain't gonna last
in September we get that [__]
September early October we get the [__]
they grew you know that was stronger
than last September that's why we've
wave your [__] we get it's like a car
you wait for your car we [__] here
you know that yeah you wait for a new
car being for what we wait for new
[__] whatever you call it strange
September you crap and it's stronger
better more don't we see more Devils
last year I was only seen one devil Down
syndrome
[Music]
it's over [__] you guys think
I'd [__] you guys think I bother you
on a Sunday night to [__] to play
knock-knock here no no no no I told you
we're going deep wait what 400 300
milligrams of peace it's a light non the
edible but it's a different animal so
it's a different type of [__]
resistance you're saying Joey you showed
up on a Sunday night without stars whoa
[Music]
bam bam
listen you know what we're using our
purple red or [__] green but at the
Voodoo Lounge there's always a star
another respect for fine 11 for 9/11 and
the [__] stars of the flag look at
this one would it tail like nothing yeah
he's a baby this is a baby stars
well this is a 125 no 125 we take our
chances
saying they might be 125 there might be
185 they might be a 85 here in the
Voodoo Lounge we don't give a [__] about
mother grant see you got it we'll take
it I'm saying that's it
white [__] around anymore people we
played this game for too long the church
got what three hundred fifty episodes
four hundred what the [__] did we talk
about world peace blind kids no we talk
about the nitty-gritty
and the Johnny McGary young saintly
please that week stars and you still
[__] droolin like a banshee over there
anyway we'll get this party started you
don't mean we talked about the whole
album so nobody goes to jail and then we
stuffed the [__] podcast and that's
it and that's that I hope you had a good
time on periscope connecting you you
guys know more than anybody I love you
[__] from Bobby Sheeran - okie
spooky - [__] you know div Dave are
all you [__] I love you - Dead
Jimmy jr. right or wrong that's right
so really you'll see it's Thursday
Friday Saturday in Austin Texas at the
cap city then the following week
NYC got them if you ain't come and go
[__] yourself you probably I don't
probably watch it anyway you probably
ranch dressing and [__] over there
thinking about eating hummus with some
[__] people named whatever the [__]
that name anyway shut the window to a
number three alright anyway why bring up
old memories let's do this [__] I'll see
you guys in 10 minutes stay black with
Joey loves you I hope you enjoyed the 22
bun it's like I was in a body but